of the physical side
I think there's um it's very important
for men in particular
to activate this sympathetic nervous
system I mean as you know that there's
two there's the paraces and pathetic now
they've got the autonomic nervous system
then you've got you know the sympathetic
numbers and they have the
parasympathetic things the sympathetic
nervous system is activated with flight
or flight where a situation where
someone pulls out a knife or something
this is where your pupils will dilate
and then you know the adrenaline will be
secreted and all these kind of things in
a situation where it's life or death or
worse you your life is an endangered
your children's life or your woman's
life your wife's life or whatever it may
be you need to be able to act in a good
way but if you if you have not activated
your sympathetic nervous system
if you not put yourself in uncomfortable
positions in the past where you know how
to deal in a situation of danger then
the likelihood of you doing something
cowardly going back to what the prophet
said that the worst of men are the ones
who are most miserly and most cowardly
it exponentially increases okay you'll
never forgive yourself
the the situation where you can do
something
where your wife will lose respect for
you for the rest of your life where your
children will never see you as a man
again
exponentially increases
um you you may do something like we've
seen videos of this I mean unfortunately
we've seen I'm not going to mention any
names
coming online now but a person getting
slapped in front of his son he doesn't
respond or another person his his
daughter that the dog comes and tries to
bite his daughter and he leaves his
daughter jumps on the top of the car you
know these kind of things you know he's
the young daughter yeah why are these
men in these positions they're in this
position because they have not taken
their role as a kawam as a protector and
maintainer seriously and uh they are not
um they are not equipped
they think in theory yes I would do this
but the matter is not a theoretical one
the matter is an experiential one when
you're in the situation it's a
milliseconds to decide what you're going
to do and if you haven't practiced that
in uh in an environment in a gym in a
martial arts center yeah and that's
probably one of the best things to do
too you I mean martial arts is the go-to
here because it's the best thing we can
do I mean in in Holland you've also got
you've got a culture of kickboxes
definitely I don't recommend heavy heavy
setting kickboxing only because it does
damage the brain and there's the hormone
I can't recommend something which
there's there's some issues with
although it's important to know the
basics of kickboxing and kickboxing is
better than uh boxing
I mean if you put a kickboxer with the
boxer the book Q box will win yeah but
why because the kickboxer has a a
portfolio that the boxer doesn't have
the moment the kickboxer kicks the box
down the leg the guy will be shocked
yeah the Box will be absolutely sure so
what's what might be interesting as well
for people is they might look at martial
arts as being like something that
doesn't have any uh correlation with the
Islamic values but protecting your
family protecting your family members
protecting your wife protecting your
children is something of course which is
very important as a Muslim so we can tie
this in I mean yeah absolutely who died
9 11. Ah
actually wrote a book called
hastening towards grappling Masala
meaning wrestling and you know this is
literally a book that was written it's
actually been translated okay recently
okay into the English language
which so one of the things is I mean
there's a famous Hadith
you know wrestling with him and the the
holiday used to be a wrestler used to be
a proper wrestler you know you'll find
that I'm not sure if you guys know this
the the sport which Muslims are most
successful in in the Olympics practicing
Muslim people or Muslim people is
Freestyle Wrestling
is Freestyle Wrestling and it has this
also in the religion of Islam if you
look Iran you look at the Russians the
pakistanis and chechnyans
even though he's not really a wrestler
he's a player
um but he's a great Grappler you know uh
you know you have this is a guy now
called
who is like pound for pound the best
wrestler in the world right now he is
from Dagestan
this impetus has turkey is a great
nation by the way Azerbaijan is a great
nature for that Kazakhstan they have
great this impetus comes from an Islamic
root there is a Islamic root for example
the Hadith
foreign
and they really wanted to go into war
so the prophet didn't allow them in the
beginning and then he allowed them and
he said the one who wins a wrestling
match between you two the one who wins
will go to war
so he used rest and this is the
wrestling was used as a barometer to
judge fortitude in character but if
you've done martial arts before you I I
personally think that wrestling
Freestyle Wrestling is the most tiring
and most exhausting of all of them of
all of them yeah because it's the the
mentality is different to for example
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu that is kind of slow
compared to wrestling is um someone will
be upset with me by saying that but it's
the truth yeah you can't compare the
pace of Freestyle Wrestling with the
pace of Brazilian Jiu Jitsu even
kickboxing is not the same but even
though that's quite it's a heavy pace
and you can get knocked out in there you
can't get enough time doesn't it it's
full body yeah yeah yeah but wrestling
is really tight if someone's like
Freestyle Wrestling properly it's a very
extremely tiring thing and it's mental
toughness resilience
the American Psychological Association
defines resilience our toughness as the
ability to deal
with
um with adversity and continue
and you in in the psychological
literature there's
um there is a concept there's two
concepts one called homeostasis and the
other one called stasis
homeostasis is keeping a balance you
know a physical and mental bad but I
think it's Alice aliose
I might be getting that wrong but it's
to be able to keep balanced despite the
pressure that you're getting so for
example if you're in a situation where
situations become more fearful or you're
in a fight or something your ability to
keep balanced in that situation is a
different measurement to your ability to
keep balance in a normal situation
and in addition to increasing your
sympathetic nervous system or being able
to activate it and not to do with it you
need to be able to increase your
threshold for being able to deal with
stress in high range environments that's
why a wrestler versus a businessman
who's never yeah if they go into a fight
the wrestler is going to annihilate him
even in a normal life situation martial
arts and these kinds of things can
actually make you more resilient in life
grief happens something bad happens to
your family something is something which
requires you it will make you a tougher
person and we are living in an age where
the sedentary position has become the
normative one where you're sitting down
the system that's that's what it is
you're sitting down on your phone that's
what your your thumbs have become so
muscular
you know but that's not how um the men
of the middle age Middle Ages were
living yeah I think it was even uh I
think Plato Plato's Socrates who said uh
you shouldn't teach your child any uh
philosophy until they're 30 but you
should teach them wrestling
in that whole period wrestling is a
Plato himself was a wrestler people
don't realize that you know in the group
times you have people like Aristotle who
by the way he he was the personal tutor
for Alexander the Great who died 323.
but Plato who was who was a teacher of
Aristotle both Plato and Aristotle were
restless they did Freestyle Wrestling
and so there was before there used to be
this kind of
merge all this um you know
symbiotic relationship between the
physical
and the mental yeah now that's been
separated now there's two separate
hierarchies if you've got you I've
rarely seldomly met someone who's at the
highest level of academic achievement in
both those fields if you're an Olympic
wrestler have you ever met an Olympic
wrestler who is at the top level of an
intellectual field I haven't I haven't
you have you know there's boxes like
Vladimir Klitschko have achieved a PhD
and so on but these things these people
are far fewer number I'm not just saying
assuming a PhD like actual knowledge
contribution in the field
so now as Muslim men
the idea should be to to Excel and to be
part of the hierarchy in both of those
things so to be competitive
in a knowledge environment in the DNA
environment but also to be competitive
in a physical environment
and if we can achieve that then we've
we've achieved a lot and I think we're
in a very good position to be able to do
so
so in terms of physical engagement you
need we need a cardio program we need a
physical strengths and strength and
conditioning program I mean on my
channel we've got recently I've put up
this three-day split of like I've got a
bodybuilder to come on to the you know
the thing and he's telling us how to fit
everything in the whole body in a few
days but we've just filmed the second
one yeah doing the deadlifts but wrong
he was showing me like you've got to do
it like this and so on but you know
you've got a little bit weights because
weights in fact increases your
testosterone and testosterone is not
something to be taken uh lightly because
having higher testosterone and lower
estrogen or optimal testosterone within
range testosterone and within range
estrogen
can actually inform your mood like I do
blood tests on a regular basis and when
I'm down in a bit like in a more sad
state
I checked my blood
and lo and behold my estrogen is higher
I don't know what causes what but the
idea is so my estrogen is high so if I
want to
being a bit more positive State I have
to manipulate my testosterone I can't do
that using uh drugs for more than one
reason by the way one of them is that
I'm taking blood thinners and that
thickens the blood but that's something
else
what I found really interesting as well
is an Insight that I received and uh
there was a medical uh practitioner who
confirmed this as well it's basically
that when we are uh when we are
experiencing fight or flight situations
we we don't only experience those
situations from physical trust but also
um like getting shouted at by your boss
or even a uh yeah or even a uh um a bill
that we get that we can't pay this
triggers the same fight and flight uh
reaction in us and basically what uh I
understood is that the only uh like
natural way to
um dismiss this fight or flights uh
tension that is built up in your body is
physically and when you think about it
fight and flight are both physical as
well so we are experiencing similar uh
triggers which trigger the fight and
flight syndrome but if we don't have
physical activity in our life there's no
way to basically output it in a healthy
way it's not about dismissing it for me
it's about managing it and yeah so for
example it's very interesting I think a
lot of it is context specific as well
there's you know Anthony Joshua he was a
former heavyweight champion yeah yeah he
was defeated by Isaac a smaller man but
more technical than him yeah and um he
defeated him and then afterwards you
know he's now rematching him or maybe he
doesn't want to rematch him because why
would he want to Revenge him
um there was a there was a video of an
answer to Joshua
doing um
mountain climbing or something right
with the harness and stuff as always you
find this online but it was like a thing
I saw someone saw this man I thought
this is very interesting because the guy
that he was with was much more confident
much more Brave if you want to put it
that way and Anthony Joshua genuinely
looked scared
doing Mountain you know that's what we
call it rock climbing yeah yeah showing
the mountains sure he looks good
but why would the heavyweight champion
of the world be scared of anything well
because it's context specific a lot of
it is based on competence if you know
you're not good at something you can
screw it up you get scared about it
the number one thing people are actually
scared of according to American polls is
public speaking Yeah because of the fear
of if it goes wrong people are going to
boo me or if I'm going to be rejected or
something like that somebody can be
really really comfortable when it comes
to public speaking but when it comes to
rock climbing be very scary my fear was
jumping into a swimming pool
you know I tried to keep like her head
first I kept getting this image of my
brain coming out of my head and blood
going everywhere but you're a tall guy
as well behind it so you might be afraid
that your feet would just hit the bottom
we would I would break your knees fears
but you know when I see people jump from
a very tall Place yeah into the water I
think this is how they do that I think
how the hell are they doing but the
point is a lot of it is context specific
and no one started off by jumping like
that they started by doing little
cannonballs and they're so important to
jump like that and then they go higher
and higher and higher the same thing is
the same with with every single thing so
martial arts is important but you can
also activate your sympathetic nervous
yeah I'm doing rock climbing or doing uh
swimming diving or lots of other things
so the idea is to get active and I think
this even helps in this might sound it's
uh crazy but in an academic setting or
not even an academic setting but like in
a debating setting like
um being able or being prepared for a
physical altercation that might occur
due to the specific debates if you're
confident in your physical competencies
then you're way more comfortable in the
debate as well absolutely and you're way
more Brave in the stand the stances you
take right so it even helps you in in
like propagating the the message that
you want especially if you want to do on
the ground this is that's undoubted yeah
the case the idea is oh I was making my
hormones is that we should also be in
tune with our hormones we should know
what the levels are so strong is
um because there are natural ways of
increasingly there are natural ways of
if your estrogen is too high there's a
natural way of reducing that so we we
need to kind of I'm in tune with it
because I had to be because I was taking
some medications that messed up my
hormonal uh production whatever but now
you know I'm looking at it very closely
and I think that's a very important
thing that people pay a bit of money do
a homework test and see what they're on
yeah so they have to have this needs to
be an output whereby there is some level
of physical activity whether it's
especially or weights are important I
mean I don't really like I don't find it
enjoyable to be honest doing well I just
do it because I have to I feel like I
have to my body needs to feel that pump
it needs to feel good so you're saying
martial arts you're seeing some weights
some ways martial arts checking your
hormone levels yeah checking hormones
yeah do a bit of cardio as well like
that's one thing that I'm struggling
with a little cardio obviously you can
do your cardio through martial arts yeah
but you have to do a bit of cardio
getting the the heart muscle strong
getting you know the lungs working it
has so many benefits it makes you yeah
live longer so uh okay the third thing
is
so we said that really the mind and the
body and we said the soul I think we're
coming with everything yeah